Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, weißt du eigentlich, wen allen Entscheidungen der Nachkriegsgeschichte immer auf der falschen Seite stand?
Nö, ich weiß aber, wer vor dem Krieg immer auf der falschen Seite stand.
Netzpolitik Nummer vierhundertundsechs vom, was haben wir heute? 13 September 20 einundzwanzig,
Und da sitzt man wieder, früh am Morgen und müssen uns äh mit den Händen wieder auf die Köppe schlagen und uns denken so, alter Schwede.
Was erlaube Armin Laschet wirklich also der.
Ist wirklich nicht mehr schön.
Eine Beleidigung für Deutschland ist das, wirklich, ja. Da passt dann auch unsere Sendungsnummer wunderbar heute äh wie Arsch auf einmal, wirklich. HTTP Fehlercode vier, null, sechs, ja,
Nord Exceptable.
Ich glaube, ich sehe grade, ich blicke gerade auf dein vorgesehenes Episodenbild, also Tim twittert ja immer mit Bild.
Und ich sehe das gerade und ich muss zugeben, das trifft es.
Gut. Das ist wild, das äh denke ich dann auch in den zu sehen. Und es heißt.
Ja genau, das sind nämlich die harte TP Cads. Da sind wir schon drauf hingewiesen worden, dass wir da noch nicht drauf hingewiesen haben. Man gibt's nämlich dann auch wirklich ein schönes Katzenbild. Für jeden hatte die Fehler. Ja, den Spaß war da auch noch mit raus.
Auf jeden Fall ähm will ich jetzt gar nicht so viel hier über diese Fehlermeldung,
sagen, man sieht sie nämlich sowieso selten genug. Das ist nämlich so diese ganzen Probleme mit diesem Web ist halt auch, man hat sich das irgendwie mal ausgedacht, wie das dann wohl eigentlich, was man eigentlich so alles bräuchte und dann hat man das alles so ins Bild in Betrieb genommen und festgestellt, so
alles gar nicht so auf, wie wir uns das gedacht haben. Es gibt so Fehlermeldungen, die will man irgendwie auch gar nicht sehen. Deswegen haben wir die auch noch nie gesehen
am Ende dann doch immer irgendwie na.
Na ja, in irgendwelche Webseiten umgesetzt werden. Das heißt, man klickt dann auf Fehlermeldungen und muss dann so als Enduser mit so,
technischen Fehlermeldungen klarkommen, womit man eigentlich gar nicht klarkommen will. Ihr kennt das auch von E-Mail, wenn irgendwie so
E-Mailsystem schicken in irgendeiner,
bei kryptischen Sprache zu erläutern, was jetzt gerade wieder schief gegangen ist, man kann schon von Glück reden, wenn man die Sprache überhaupt versteht, indem dieser E-Mails aber mit allem redet. Das ist auf jeden Fall alles ganz schön,
kaputt und da merkt man auch mal wieder, dass dass da irgendwie auch noch ein langer Weg zu gehen ist. Aber so oder so.
Auf jeden Fall Armin Laschet, das, das ist dein Statuscode.
Aber äh ich weiß gar nicht, wann der kommt. Also.
Wenn du halt eine falsch formulierte Anfrage hast, wenn du halt irgendwie Dinge ähm,
im Rahmen von, also es gibt ja diese ja, wo du halt sagen kannst, so ja, hallo, ich bin's, ich hätte gerne was von dir, aber ich hätte es gerne in diesem Format und das sind die Formate, die ich kann.
Und wenn der Server das halt nicht kann, wenn er das nicht liefern kann, was der Klein angefragt hat, in welchem Format er das gerne haben will, dann dann gibt es ein
ich verstehe dieses Format nicht. Du kannst ja in diesem HTTP Header mitschreiben, was du für Formate unterstützt, was für mein du kannst und ob du das jetzt gerne,
haben möchtest oder nicht, so du äußerst sozusagen deine Wünsche und wenn diese Wünsche auf der anderen Seite nicht erfüllt werden können, dann ist es halt.
Okay, verstehe.
Unspektakulär. Ja, das ist, ich meine, das werden wir dann demnächst wahrscheinlich äh in den Koalitionsverhandlungen dann sehen,
dass genau dieses Problem ist, dass halt die äh alle so mit so Wunschvorstellungen daherkommen, wo dann die anderen sagen so, ja nee,
Geht so nicht. Kann man so nicht machen und so geht das dann die ganze Zeit hin und her.
Auf gar keinen Fall gibt es mit Unsteuererhöhungen oder Steuersenkungen oder Steuern überhaupt noch. Und dann am Ende.
Ich habe heute, da war auch, ich wollte eigentlich nochmal äh einen Versuch machen, mir dieses anzugucken und dann.
Mit Quad-Quartet oder so was. Da waren dann schwierig. Dass sie sich überlegen. Da waren der Lindner.
Frau Weidel.
Haben sie über irgendeine Studie, die dann ausgerechnet hat, dass das, was die AfD geredet hat, Unsinn ist? Und dann sagt die Wahl, ach ja, die Studie ist war falsch,
Studie, ne? Und das alles völlig falsche Studien. Und dann denkst du so, ja okay,
vor sich hin. Und der Lindner tanzt los und sagt, ja die Studie ist wirklich schlecht, da muss ich der Frau Weidel recht geben und meint dann irgendwie, dass das nicht berücksichtigt, dass die Studie nicht adäquat die Steuersenkungspläne der FDP gewürdigt hätte.
Und wo die
und dann sagte die Moderatorin, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, wer die Moderatorin ist, sagt so, ja, also sie haben Finanzierungsloch von 90 Milliarden Euro, wo wollen sie das denn herkriegen, ne? Und Herr Linda, die Studie, die Studie, die Studie, ne, sie so, ja okay, können sie mir bitte sagen, wo sie 90 Millionen Euro her 90 Milliarden Euro herholen? Ja, aber die Studie ist
ey, das war das kannst du dir nicht angucken. Du kannst es dir nicht angucken. Da habe ich's auch wieder ausgemacht.
Ich weiß nicht, wann konntest du dir denn das letzte Mal im Fernsehen was angucken? Ich kann mir das schon so sehr lange nicht angucken.
Geht nicht, geht nicht. Geht nicht, Fernsehen. Ich habe aber deshalb nie einen Fernseher gehabt.
Also ich schaue mir diese ganzen
Talkshows nicht an, ich schaue mir auch diese ganzen Debatten nicht an, weil ich einfach null Erwartungen habe. Ich habe mir wieder jetzt ein längeres Interview mit der Baerbock mal angehört, festgestellt, dass sie in der Lage ist, ganze Sätze zu bilden und auch Fragen antworten kann. Mehr muss ich nicht wissen.
Ich meine, das ist ja schon eine Qualität heutzutage.
Wollen wir zum Feedback kommen?
Ja. Bitte.
Okay, kommen wir zum Feedback. Höre relativ viel Feedback und ähm,
Das ist ganz interessant. Wenn wir in der letzten Sendung ein bisschen über diese Pur-Abos gesprochen und über die ähm über die Beschwerde von,
über diese Pur-Abos. Und da hat uns jetzt jemand geschrieben, die Person bleibt namentlich ungenannt. Äh guten Morgen. Ich wollte euch ein wenig Hintergrundinformationen zu den Purabos geben.
Euch in Folge 4hundert4 ja über Pur Abos und vor allem die hohen Preise der selben gewundert.
Ich arbeite bei einem, der von euch genannten Medienhäuser als Entwickler.
Ich kann natürlich nur für dieses Medienhaus sprechen, bei dem ich angestellt bin, aber bei uns ging es bei dem Pur-Abonie darum, damit wirklich Abonnements abzuschließen.
Hier wurde mit allen möglichen Mitteln versucht, die Leute dazu zu bringen, ihre Einwilligung zu geben. Das Abo wurde befristet und wird nicht automatisch verlängert
Im Gegensatz zu unserem Plus Abo, welches automatisch verlängert wird. Es wird außer auf der Einwilligungsseite, soweit ich weiß nicht, beworben,
und es gibt keine besonderen Werbekampagnen dafür,
Soweit es uns mitgeteilt wurde, lohnt es sich vielmehr die Einwilligungen zu bekommen, als wir fast 5 Euro einen Monatsabo zu bekommen, zumindest solange nicht ein Großteil aller aufrufenden ein Abo abschließt.
Vor dem Pur-Abo konnte man bei uns die Zustimmung zu einzelnen Punkten entziehen,
Wobei wir auch hier gezwungen waren, Dark Patterns anzuwenden. Also Muster, die einfach dafür gebaut sind, dass du nicht das kriegst, was du eigentlich möchtest. Trotzdem haben viele unserer Nutzer davon Gebrauch gemacht.
Was wohl zu einem ziemlichen Umsatzeinbruch geführt hat.
Daher wurde viel Druck gemacht, um das Pur aber möglichst schnell umzusetzen und anschließend nur noch eine allgemeine Einwilligung zu ermöglichen.
Hier in der Abteilung sind viele nicht gerade glücklich über den aktuellen Zustand des Online-Werbemarktes. Auch wenn uns allen bewusst ist, dass damit,
unser Gehalt verdient wird oder zumindest ein Teil davon. Das wurde auch intern zum Ausdruck gebracht, aber natürlich ignoriert.
Ich persönlich wünsche neu mit der Beschwerde viel Erfolg. Ich habe die Seele so allgemein wie möglich gehalten, damit ihr sie problemlos zitieren könnt. Das ist hiermit geschehen.
Und ja, das ist halt, das zeigt tatsächlich nochmal ein anderes Bild von den Purabos als, ja, ich es bisher hatte,
damit macht natürlich die Beschwerde von nochmal umso mehr Sinn. Ich meine, für mich kam es ich fand das Angebot immer immer schon komisch und es macht natürlich,
es erst recht dann Sinn, wenn es im Prinzip dafür da ist, die Einwilligung zu zu forcieren, ja? Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an.
Dass bei Podcast ja jetzt auch der die ähm die Benennung als Abonnement wegfällt
weil die Leute, weil die festgestellt haben, dass Abonnement äh als etwas Negatives wahrgenommen wird, ne. Also es heißt jetzt irgendwie,
füge diesen Podcast hinzu, ne? Folge diesem Podcast und so. Aber das, was man 20 Jahre lang gemacht hat, nämlich Subscribe, hat eben oder abonnieren,
hat das,
den schlechten Beigeschmack des Abonnements und der Abo Falle. Und deswegen ist natürlich irgendwie schon auch interessant, halt zu sagen, ey jo, wir machen euch hier jetzt ein Pur abonnement. Ja, und alle denken dann so, nee, wir kommen dann lieber dann lieber nicht.
Fand ich sehr, sehr schönen Einblick noch mal in diese in diese Dark-Petterns.
Ja, dieses Umstellen von Subskripeb auf Follow, ich glaube Apple will das irgendwie auch machen oder hat's schon gemacht, ich weiß es gerade gar nicht, das ja. Also YouTube macht das ja interessanterweise nicht, ne.
Ich wollte also ich fand jetzt eher diesen diesen Aspekt halt. Also was, glaube ich, schon auf jeden Fall geht, ist, dass du mit Abo, mit Abo Leute versuchen kannst zu verscheuchen, ne? Und das scheint ja.
Und dass sie hier, wenn du wenn äh wenn du ein Abo machst, also das das ist, glaube ich, auch wirklich das verräterischste, ne. Wenn du ein Abo machst und das ist nicht automatisch verlängernd, ne? Dann bist du entweder wirklich doof.
Oder es geht dir wirklich nicht darum, dieses Abo abzuschließen. So ein Abo Falle. Eine Abofalle mit du kommst aus der Abo-Falle frei,
Karte, ja, das ist irgendwie nicht äh, äh, nicht, nicht, nicht vorgesehen, ne?
Ja, also auf jeden Fall ich meine, es ist natürlich auch um vielleicht mal so diese Online.
Medien bisschen auch zu verstehen oder verstehen zu wollen, dieser dieser dieser Spagat zwischen man will so viel Reichweite haben wie möglich.
Und man will aber auch irgendwo bezahlt werden, ne? Ähm.
Ist auch nicht einfach aufzulösen. Ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt sagen könnte, ja, ihr müsst ja nur X machen und dann funktioniert das.
Weil du eben auch noch andere Player am Markt hast,
für die andere äh Regeln gelten, die andere Ziele haben oder die andere Finanzierungsquellen haben,
die dann entsprechend einfach sagen können, ah bei uns gibt's aber hier alles irgendwie kostenlos zu lesen und wenn Artikel hinter Paywalls äh verschwinden oder wenn eben ne, dann.
Senkst du auch automatisch deine Reichweite und damit natürlich auch automatisch den Wert dieses Abos? Und
Leute schließen es dann wieder nicht ab. So, also willst du dann doch wieder der Öffentlichkeit sein. Dann musst du aber deine Inhalte kostenlos äh bereitstellen und wie machst du das, halt ohne Werbung oder so und das ist es ist schon ein schon ein Problem
Sehe das, dass es ein Problem ist, aber ich find's auch total unangemessen, dass jetzt eben so viel Dark Patternce permanent,
verwendet werden. Und das man eigentlich auch so die ganze Zeit so das Vertrauen auch verliert, dass man einfach so der erste Kontakt mit so einem Medium ist dann immer so, ja ich versuche dich, hallo willkommen bei der Webseite, die versucht dich zu irgendwas zu zwingen, was du jetzt eigentlich gar nicht möchtest.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen ein Drama.
Ganz viel zu Bundestagswahl Feedback bekommen.
Ich fand übrigens, ich hatte das schon im Anschluss an die Sendung gesagt, fand er unseren Bundestagswahl nicht so gut, wie er hätte sein können.
Weil wir irgendwie bei Tim sich von mir animiert fühlte, auch nicht zu sagen,
wen, wen er wählen möchte. Mein Hintergrund, nichts zu sagen, wen ich wähle, war so ein bisschen, ich wurde von äh hier Monitor,
Die machen so eine Social-Kampagne, die läuft jetzt wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie bald. Irgendwie wen wählst du, wo die Frage gestellt wird, an die Leute, wen wählst du, ja? Da wurde, habe ich mitgemacht und haben's auch,
Also ich weiß nicht, wen sie denn noch alles gefragt hat. Einzelne Personen, die sie auch gefragt haben, weiß ich, das ist mir,
kalt den Rücken runtergelaufen, andere äh fand ich sehr schön. Ähm also müsste jetzt irgendwann bald in ihrem Instagram oder wo auch immer erscheinen, keine Ahnung, wo die das alles machen.
Und den hatte ich halt vorher gesagt, so, naja, wenn ihr wenn ihr mich da als äh CCC Vertreter fragt, dann kann ich ja nicht
'ne spezifische Wahlempfehlung aussprechen ja? Aber ich kann natürlich sehr sehr klar sagen dass ich nicht AfD und nicht CDU wähle,
und ähm
den den Rest kann man sich wahrscheinlich aus meinen Schwerpunkten und meinen Positionen denken. Aber ich find's ja auch, hatte ja auch, glaube ich, hier schon letzte Mal gesagt, dass ich das oder auf Twitter gebe ich das häufig bekannt. Ich hoffe halt, dass die Leute,
dass sie dass die Leute halt etwas nachdenken und wählen, auch wenn ich natürlich der der Versuchung,
schwer widerstehen kann, mir einzubilden, dass jetzt die Leute irgendetwas wählen, weil ich das empfohlen habe. Das ist natürlich auch wieder so ein bisschen,
quatschig, aber als jemand, der viel ähm sowohl mit der,
mit den Grünen als auch mit der Linkspartei im im Bundestag zusammenarbeitet, ne? Fährt es mir natürlich schwer, hier eine eine Empfehlung auszusprechen. Ich möchte ja, dass äh alle denken, ich hätte sie gewählt, inklusive der FDP.
Ah, du möchtest, dass die von dir denken, du könntest sie vielleicht unter Umständen trotzdem noch gewählt haben.
Ja, selbstverständlich. Ich ich möchte von denen umgarnt werden.
Ja, wer will das nicht? Ja, ich habe ähm.
Mir ging's auch erstmal um was anderes. Äh ich wollte eigentlich glaube ich erstmal so ein bisschen meine meine Miniatur zerrissen, die jetzt wirklich mega groß ist. Äh
erstmal hinstellen und so die Überlegungen, die ich mir jetzt im äh in meiner Rolle als Erstwähler äh sozusagen überhaupt das erste Mal so,
nicht unbedingt das erste Mal selber gestellt habe, aber das erste Mal eben konkret auch selber gespürt habe. Weil's ja immer was anderes ist, irgendwas zu machen als nur darüber zu reden. Mal so als ganz allgemeine Maxime, immer wieder eine interessante Erkenntnis,
Dinge sind anders, wenn man sie wirklich tun muss, anstatt nur zu behaupten, dass man sie tun würde. Ja,
Naja, ich meine, also dieses, was man wählt.
Ich kann irgendwie relativ einfach runterbrechen, was mir eigentlich äh lieb wäre. Mir wäre es ganz lieb, wenn wir nicht eine
so ein Weiter so Dingsbums hätten, weil ich finde, dass die Leute, die so die letzten,
zehn, 15, zwanzig Jahre mitgewirkt haben, na ja, das war halt nicht so geil, so.
Ja, da musste Armin Laschet wählen, der hatte jetzt ganz klar gesagt, so kann das nicht weitergehen. Der hätte jetzt Zukunft.
Mein Motto. Genau mein Motto.
Genau mein Ding, ey. Armen Nasched, ich sage es dir. Der wird jetzt hier alles auf auf den Kopf stellen. Der macht das jetzt alles richtig.
Hm. Ja, da habe ich doch so ein bisschen meine Zweifel. Also.
Na gut, dann musste äh Olaf Scholz wählen. Der hat jetzt zwar die letzten, weiß ich nicht, acht Jahre mitgewirkt, aber der hat sich halt jetzt auch eingesehen, dass das ähm an alles anders muss.
Ja, ich erinnere mich da bloß an so eine Sendung, die wir mal gehabt haben
spielte der Olaf Scholz auch schon äh eine besondere äh Rolle. Du erinnerst dich vielleicht, wir haben hier mal ein wunderschönes äh G20 äh Spezial gemacht. Ähm.
Bisschen Kärcher.
Na ja.
Tim.
Sendung noch gleich, dringende Bitte. Logbuchnetzpolitik zweihundertfünfundzwanzig vom zehnten Juli zwanzig siebzehn
Und John Elf Nebel zu Gast hatten, der uns mal ausführlich äh berichtet hat, was da eigentlich alles so gelaufen ist. Und ich fand das schon wirklich alles extrem erschreckend. Und ähm das ist halt so diese typische.
Jetzt bin ich hier so an der Macht, jetzt jetzt muss ich hier irgendwie so das dieses dieses konservative,
durchsetzen und das fängt erstmal damit an, dass alles, was irgendwie links ist und alles, was irgendwie bewegt ist,
das geht jetzt erstmal gar nicht, ne? Und wenn hier sowas staatstragendes wie so ein G20-Gipfel äh äh kommt, dann ist einfach Widerspruch nicht erlaubt. Und dann ist es uns eigentlich auch egal, wie wir da vorgehen. So und dann wird halt einfach Polizei rangekarrt und dann wird einfach so lange draufgeklopft
und äh Leuten, die eigentlich gar nichts gemacht haben, die Schuld zugeschoben, das das ist ja so ein wiederkehrendes Pattern.
Das finde ich halt einfach inakzeptabel und dementsprechend ist natürlich jetzt mein Verhältnis zu Herrn Scholz gebrochen.
Dann musst du dann musste Armin Laschet wählen.
Ach, schon wieder.
Weil na ja, ach, wo nee, der hat ja den äh Hambacher Forst äh wieder richtig räumen lassen, weil er den, weil er die heraushaben wollte. Hm.
Ja und war auch noch blöd genug zuzugeben, dass er da nur einen Vorwand gesucht hat. Also das ist halt.
Das ist halt so diese Methode. Ja, da kommt dann leider irgendwie für mich diese SPD auch nicht in Frage, schon gar nicht in Berlin mit dieser furchtbaren Giffy.
Ähm einfach auch für alles steht, was ich hier nicht haben will.
So, mit anderen Worten, was bleibt da noch groß über, ja, also ähm ich finde ja so den Gedanken äh mal von einer äh von einer jungen Person hier äh angeführt zu werden in Deutschland, finde ich ja wirklich extrem bestechend.
Irgendwie persönlich nicht, ähm aber wie schon erwähnt, habe ich so den Eindruck,
Sätze nicht auf den Kopf gefallen ist. Wie die das mit äh halbwegs stringenz und ähm Intelligenz gesegnet, ausreichend, um mich da äh entsprechend anzusprechen. Und ich fänd's halt ganz okay, wenn dies vielleicht machen würde.
Achso, meine meine einfache, grundlegende Überlegung an der Stelle. Ja, und dementsprechend müsste ich dann halt auch wählen.
Man muss auch einfach mal sagen, Deutschland ist einfach nur nicht bereit für 'ne männliche Kanzlerin. Das betone ich immer wieder.
Ja, das ist in der Tat auch noch so ein Problem, ne. Also jetzt so ein Mann, ich weiß nicht. Männer, finde ich, haben sich nicht so bewährt auch.
Kannst du das kannst du wirklich äh nicht sagen, dass sich Männer bewährt hätten, ja.
Nee, ist einfach, die machen nur Ärger.
Insofern ist es ein bisschen finde ich ein bisschen dramatisch, dass das so diese anfängliche Euphorie sich äh nicht hat, wieder äh herstellen lassen, dass er natürlich alles etwas aufgepumpt war, zu Beginn ist klar,
Aber warum es den Gründen jetzt auch nicht gelingt, da ihre äh.
Diese diesen Angriff mal richtig zu führen, weiß ich nicht. Also.
Man weiß auch immer nicht, wer wer da alles dreht. Diese ganze mediale Darstellung, dieses ganzen Zirkus ist natürlich auch einfach äh immer mit Skeptisch zu nehmen. Deswegen schaue ich mir halt auch diese ganzen inszenierten Veranstaltungen gar nicht erst an
Ja, dann bleiben halt noch so die Linken, die halt irgendwie.
In vielen Bereichen für mich auch schwierig sind, also Bereichen meine ich's halt für bestimmte Personen und bestimmte Untergruppen,
aber die hast du halt eigentlich auch überall, ja,
Bei manchen mehr, bei manchen weniger. Du hast immer so ein paar Vollidioten am Start. Ich meine, die CDU hatte immer irgendwie ihren äh rechtskonservativen äh Bereich am Start. Haben sie ja immer noch da mit Herrn Maaßen und vorher war es diese äh,
und und so andere Vollidioten, die halt jetzt alle dann zur äh AfD gewackelt sind, weil's irgendwie ihn zu links wurde in der CDU.
Ist auch geil irgendwie, wenn man auf sowas überhaupt.
Es war innerhalb nie rechts genug.
Das ist ja das, was sie meinen mit Linksrutsch. Ja, wie erdrutsch.
Ja und bei den Linken gibt's halt auch so ein paar äh Vögel hier, wie diese Wagenknecht, die halt auch nicht gehen,
Ganz klar, aber am Ende und wir haben das ja hier auch öfter schon angeschnitten ähm und wir hatten ja auch bei unserer äh LNP ähm.
LNP na? Zwei.
Ich glaube, das war die dreihundert oder zweihundertfünfundsechzig.
Das war die zweihundertfünfundsechzig, genau. Wo wir Martina äh Renner da hatten, die halt so für mich so ein.
Vertreter äh ist äh sehr viel mehr für die Linken, steht wie ich sie wahrnehme. Ja, dass sie einfach wirklich sehr,
viele Leute sind, die sich äh tatsächlich mit mit der politischen Situation in Deutschland doch sehr intensiv auseinandersetzen und nicht nur irgendwelche Dampfplauderer sind. Und da auch einfach eine ganz klare,
Position haben, wie so in ihrem Fall halt so eine ganz klare Antifasfaschistische äh Position,
und die sich halt auch reinnördet und die Untersuchungsausschüsse äh verfolgt et cetera. Und das ist schon so eine,
so 'ne Oppositionsqualität die ich die ich jetzt nicht vermissen möchte im Bundestag. Das wär halt,
schade, wenn das wegfällt, ne.
Tim, möchtest du noch zum Feedback kommen eigentlich? Ich frage nur.
Ja, wir möchten gleich noch zum Feedback kommen, aber da du das ja jetzt konkret bemängelt hast, ja.
Ich habe nix bemängelt.
Doch, du hast bemängelt, dass dass wir letzte Mal nicht so richtig klar geworden sind. Da dachte ich mir so, gut, dann dann werden wir doch mal jetzt einfach mal klar und ich sage einfach mal, was so mein Gedanken äh Gang dabei ist, ne, weil ich habe da jetzt auch nicht so ein Problem damit, mich
mich da irgendwie an der Stelle irgendwie zu verorten, weil am Ende ist für mich die Sache äh sehr einfach zu reduzieren so.
Ich hätte halt gern eine, eine, eine, eine Regierung, die sehr viel linker angeordnet ist, als es derzeit ist. Ich bin mir darüber im Klaren, dass das in Deutschland nicht sich beliebig weit nach links verschieben lässt
uns vielleicht auch nicht so eine super geile Idee ist, wenn's zu links wäre.
Weil wir dann eben auch gleich wieder so ein äh Backlash äh haben, der die Sache schnell wieder aus dem Gleichgewicht bringen kann. Man sieht das ja auch in Berlin.
Aber ich möchte gerne, dass dieses Klimaproblem jetzt wirklich mal angegangen wird und ich habe einfach nicht den Eindruck, dass irgendwie mit SPD und CDU da irgendwas vorangeht, irgendwas,
nichts wird da passieren. Das ist einfach die Wahrheit so. Ob mit einer grünen geführten Bundesregierung,
es wirklich besser wird, kann ich nicht sagen. Ich kann nur sagen, mit den anderen wird's bestimmt nicht besser,
So und das reicht mir an der Stelle einfach als Ausschlusskriterium vollkommen aus und äh von daher.
Meine Wahl so in die Richtung gehen.
Okay, dann kommen wir zum Feedback zum Thema strategisch wählen.
Also wir haben da ähm verschiedenste Kommentare bekommen, ich zitiere Magido, er schreibt, ich fand
die für wieder um die Dilemma des uns strategischen Willens, also unten in Klammern, strategischen Wählens sehr gut diskutiert von euch, entscheidet man sich zum strategischen Wählen, werden die angesprochenen Risiken, Wahrscheinlichkeiten für bestimmte Ereignisse
meist nur durch ein Bauchgefühl repräsentiert und man versucht, diese gegeneinander abzuwägen. Wer sich nicht nur auf,
Gefühlsabwägung verlassen will, findet vielleicht unsere datenbasierten Wahlprognosen hilfreich. Wir haben auf, wer gewinnt die Wahl DE,
Also wer Strich gewinnt Strich die Wahl, Strich die.
Strich Wahl DE, Twitter, Wahlprognose 21, ein Wahlprognose-Modell entwickelt, das im Gegensatz zu Wahlumfragen, Wahrscheinlichkeitsaussagen zu bestimmten Ereignissen liefert
wahrscheinlich, also zum Beispiel, wie wahrscheinlich ist ein Nichteinzug der Linkspartei, im Bundestag, wie wahrscheinlich ist eine Neuauflage der großen Koalition et cetera PP. Unser Modell ist frei und Open Saurs,
ähm ja über Feedback zum Modell und unseren Prognosen freuen wir uns. Da kann man schön drauf rumklicken und sich Wahrscheinlichkeiten anschauen.
Macht mich nicht so richtig glücklich was da steht aber interessant. Dann noch ein weiteres Feedback zum Wahlomat.
Damian schreibt, bin ich froh, dass ihr diese Wahl-O-Mat-Angebote kritisch betrachtet habt. In großen Teilen der Presse und des öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks wird so getan oder ist zumindest so tendenziös dargestellt, als wären diese Wahlomaten neuerdings Voraussetzungen fürs Wählen. Spricht man,
mit Menschen, die Politik eher naiv gegenüberstehen, gewinnt man tatsächlich diesen Eindruck, diese vielleicht nicht so beabsichtigte Fehlinformation wirkt jedenfalls,
Ich benutze diese Scheinhilfen. Nicht, wer nicht aus einem Inneren heraus durch seine Lebenserfahrung weiß, wofür die jeweiligen Parteien stehen, lebt bestimmt sehr glücklich in den Tag hinein. Fast beneidenswert.
Ja, dann beklagt er noch, dass der Wahlomat äh von der Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung äh erstellt wird,
Seit wann benötigt man für politisches Denken eine zentrale Stelle und zwar bundesweit? Nein, der eigene Kopf ist ausreichend.
Ja gut, also ich meine Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung macht gute Sachen in meinen äh Augen und ich finde das jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so verwerflich,
dass sie äh äh so ein Projekt unterstützen. Interessanter ist dann noch der Kommentar von Tanja,
Faust ein Problem mit dem Wahl-O-Mat habt ihr leider nicht thematisiert. Ihr behauptet eine größere Nähe der User zu rechtsextremen Parteien als zu vielen anderen demokratischen Parteien zumindest wenn die User aus dem linksliberalen Spektrum kommen,
Der dritte Weg oder die NPD liegen dann in der Regel von CDU und FDP, weil die für die große Mehrheit der User überragende Bedeutung der Beibehaltung eines liberalen demokratischen Systems gar nicht abgefragt wird,
Forderung des 3ten Wegs nach Einführung des nationalen Sozialismus in den Grenzen des Deutschen Reichs,
Auch diese Partei für fast alle unwählbar. Aber weil die 38 Fragen des Wahlomaten nur Thesen beinhalten, zu denen alle Parteien sich positionieren, fällt diese Haltung unter den Tisch,
vergleichsweise irrelevante Übereinstimmung mit dem dritten Weg zum Beispiel bei Elternunabhängigen BAföG hingegen zählt als Kriterium für politische Nähe. Ich finde den Wahlomat wirklich gefährlich.
Ja. Und das ist, das ist nämlich ein guter Punkt, ne, weil dieses.
Anscheinende, oh ja, wir haben ja nur diese Position hier ausgewertet, ja? Ähm,
ist halt immer so wie mit Statistiken, ne? Also es äh kommt immer drauf an, wie man fragt und was man nicht fragt und weglassungen sind da eben auch problematisch und von daher
Ja, also ich würde auch so ein so einem Apparat, also ich würde sowieso nicht so einer Maschine, egal, wie sie jetzt gebaut ist und wie toll sie ist, in irgendeiner Form
ähm überlassen zu beurteilen, was.
Zu mir angeblich passt oder nicht passt oder was was äh angeblich meine äh Interessen am besten zu vertreten beabsichtigt.
Das ist dann schon doch eher eine Gefühlssache. Ja.
Gibt's auch noch einen äh von mir Ungehörten
Podcast, der diese ganzen einzelnen Omaten analysiert augenscheinlich verlinken wir noch dazu war noch in den ähm in den Kommentaren verlinkt, ähm,
aber jetzt nichts dazu sagen, wie die Bewertung ausgefallen ist. Ja, dann wollen wir noch äh korrigiert.
Wir haben nämlich äh ich habe das, glaube ich, gesagt, ne. Ich habe gesagt, hier der Bund hält äh die Mehrheit an der Telekom,
sagt, sorry, aber der Bund hält nicht 50 Prozent an der Telekom, direkt hält er 14,5 Prozent und mittelbar über die KfW nochmal siebzehn Komma
vier Prozent macht, dreißig1,9 Prozent äh ist trotzdem zu viel, sagt er oder zu wenig, je nachdem, wie man's sieht.
Okay, ja, das äh.
Ist mir ehrlich gesagt ein wenig äh entfallen, aber es war ja mal anders. Aber trotz alledem ist natürlich das Mitspracherecht äh bei der Telekom durch den Bund durchaus gegeben.
Und dann habe ich, glaube ich, noch einen Fehler gemacht, dass ich gesagt habe, hell gebraun, ist kein Minister und da wurden wir von mehreren,
korrigiert unter anderem von Knut, hellgebrauen ist schon Bundesminister und zwar der Bundesminister für besondere Aufgaben und Dorothea ist nur Staatsministerin.
Ja, wobei ist natürlich, ich weiß nicht genau, wie man das unterscheidet, aber es gibt ja Minister, die haben sozusagen auch ein eigenes.
Ministerium und äh als Bundesminister.
Ja da bist du dann halt im Kanzleramt irgendwie äh tätig, aber äh Chefin ist natürlich die Kanzlerin.
Ähm aber du hast halt im Prinzip äh Augenhöhe mit anderen Ministern, was die Entscheidungs äh äh Wirkmächtigkeit im Kabinett betrifft et cetera.
Ja, also ist ja äh ich glaube, ist ja okay. Also oder? Kann man.
Ich wollte mich nur ein bisschen rausreden.
So dann äh gab's einen Geburtstag zu feiern.
Tja.
Gab es. Leider äh ohne große äh Party, weil wisst ihr ja, ne? Geht ja gerade alles nicht, aber ähm,
äh liegt nun der Tag, äh der inoffiziellen Ausrufungen des Chaos Computerclubs. 40 Jahre zurück.
Und da wurde dann auch das ein oder andere darüber geschrieben und berichtet, dass ähm fand ich schön. Es sind auch ein paar sehr nette Artikel bei rausgekommen.
Ähm wo das ein oder andere reflektiert wurde, das Ganze steht dann auch so ein bisschen.
In dem ja in dieser, in dieser Linie mit dem Film, alles ist eins, außer der Null, den man ja hier schon erwähnt haben und der ähm,
Ja dann doch äh hier und da immer mal wieder in Kinos lief. Ich war grade erst vor ein paar Tagen nochmal äh.
Filmrauschkino in Berlin, wo er Open Air gezeigt wurde, wo auch äh ausverkauft war und großes Interesse war.
Das fand ich doch sehr schön. Ähm ja und äh.
Außerdem ist dann auch noch äh auf unserer schon mal gescheiterte 20 Jahre Party auch verwiesen worden. Ich weiß gar nicht, haben wir da überhaupt drüber gesprochen.
Das ist sicherlich schon mal erzählt, aber äh vielleicht erzählst du's nochmal.
Ja, ich meine.
Die letzten Tage Nachrichten geschaut hat, kann sich ungefähr vorstellen, 40 Jahre CC, 20 Jahre nein, Eleven,
Wie war wohl der 20. Geburtstag des CCC 20 Jahre Bauer Holland tot, auch vor kurzem der 20 Jahrestag des CCC war wahrscheinlich.
Gemischt.
Überschattet würde ich sagen, aber definitiv,
überschattet und das war schon wirklich äh ein bisschen frustrierend damals, dass dass wir einfach wirklich so eine geile Party gebaut haben und so eine schöne Ausstellung gemacht haben und so eine geile Lichtinstallation dazu gebaut haben
Allein kommt einfach dieses nine eleven und nimmt irgendwie die ganzen den ganzen Wind aus den Segeln. Das.
Laden die verzeihen.
Äh denen wurden eine ganze Menge nicht verziehen, aber ich glaube da die Geschichte oder die Erfahrung in in dieser Zeit ging ja noch weiter, was jetzt das Projekt Blinkenleits anging. Erzähl doch mal.
Was meinst du jetzt.
Ja blinken leids hat sich doch dann doch noch zu dem wichtigen äh oder hat ja dann doch noch eine wichtige Wirkung entfaltet oder nicht.
Ja, das schon. Ich meine, das war schon ein äh von äh war schon von Vorteil, dass wir dieses Projekt nicht nur für eine Woche geplant haben. Ich meine, wir wussten ja nicht, wie lange diese Lichtinstallation laufen würde. Also.
Haben auch damit gerechnet, dass es unter Umständen nach zwei Wochen alles explodiert.
Erzähl doch erstmal, was für eine Lichtinstallation. Komm, jetzt hast du doch nicht alles aus dem Nase ziehen. Was habt ihr gemacht, Tim.
Könntest du nicht Projekt Blinkenleits erzählen?
Ja, ich weiß ja nicht, wo du einsteigen möchtest.
Indem du erklärst, was es war.
Na ja gut, also.
Da habe ich jetzt wiederum das Gefühl, dass es eh schon alle wissen. Gut, ich meine, wir haben damals.
Das Ganze ging ja mit
mit Weiß, Tod irgendwie los, dass wir ja eigentlich ursprünglich gedacht haben, so, ah, jetzt haben wir bald zwanzig Jahre CCC, dann können wir ja uns endlich mal die Geschichte des CCC äh der letzten zwanzig Jahre mal erzählen lassen. So, das war
die Vorstellung,
So, dann setzen wir einfach mal auf die Bühne und dann, dann, dann, dann, dann darf er einfach mal erzählen. So, weil wir hatten damals schon so ein bisschen dieses Problem, dass so die Kontinuität mal ein wenig in Gefahr war, weil es einfach so viele Geschichten gab und äh und so weiter
Und dann ist er halt gestorben und das hat dann letzten Endes in der Reaktion dazu geführt, dass man sich halt bei allem mehr Mühe gegeben hat. Und so ist dann halt auch aus dieser Idee, Party machen in diesem Hochhaus und dann vielleicht äh aus den Fenstern
äh da CCC draufzuschreiben, wo du dann halt schnell dieser Wahnsinn, dass wir eben dieses ganze Haus, das Haus des Lehrers am Alexanderplatz
in diesen blinkenden Bildschirm verwandelt haben.
Und das wurde ja dann zum 11. September fertig. Und äh.
Grade als es fertig war, ja und wie sie so dachten so, oh wie geil, jetzt wenn wenn sich das irgendwie alle anschauen und es auch wirklich äh nice geworden.
Kam halt einfach dieser Nine eleven Schock da drüber und hat irgendwie erstmal alle Prioritäten aller Leute komplett in eine andere Richtung gedreht. Und da musste man dann halt erstmal gegen,
anblinken und das hat dann irgendwie zwei Wochen gedauert, glaube ich, bis bis überhaupt jemand bereit war, da wirklich äh sinnvoll darauf zu reagieren. Und es war dann auch eine schwierige Situation für uns.
Weil dann hast du auf einmal so einen Bildschirm mitten in der Hauptstadt Berlins.
Mit dem du sozusagen die ganze Nacht über das Zeitgeschehen kommentieren könntest.
Ja und du darfst irgendwie nicht. Also du du hättest also es war zumindest unklar, was man jetzt hätte.
Geduld hätte durften können, aber man war natürlich dann auch so ein bisschen so im Selbstzweifel so, ja. Kommentieren wir denn das jetzt eigentlich in irgendeiner Form oder ist das schon zu nass forsch so, ne? Und äh
deswegen kam's dann halt zu diesem,
Herz, weil es einfach so ein bisschen der Kompromiss war. So, wir haben dann einfach mal drei Nächte lang, einfach nur dieses Herz durchblicken lassen,
Weil wir eben dachten so, das ist jetzt irgendwie das, was diese Stadt grade braucht. Und irgendwie haben sich dann nachher auch alle wieder so ein bisschen beruhigt.
Stellte sich heraus, dass das dann auch tatsächlich das war, was diese Stadt braucht oder nicht?
Ja, den Eindruck hatte ich schon, weil es halt diese Installation ist schon eine sehr emotionale Geschichte geworden dann in der Stadt. Also es wurde einfach,
sehr emotional aufgenommen von den Leuten. Aus aus den unterschiedlichsten Gründen und dann über die nächsten Monate, es lief ja dann noch ein halbes Jahr,
wurde das Ding halt dann auch so zum so komplett in die Popkultur mit eingesogen. So, das ist ja dann,
ich in Filmen gelandet, in in in zahlreichen Musikvideos äh verwendet äh worden. Es gab halt so ganze Welt hat darüber berichtet, dass das war dann einfach der totale,
totale äh Hit so und da habe ich ja dann auch meinen Ruf weg äh Medienkünstler zu sein. Stand im Spiegel, muss also wahr sein.
Und in der Wikipedia. Stimmt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen, ne? Aber.
Stimmt schon so ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen.
Ja, der 40 war jetzt von der Pandemie gebäuelt. Natürlich hätten wir uns alle gefreut, irgendwie in einem anderen Kontext und ja, angenehmer zu feiern. Es fehlte ein bisschen die,
Planungssicherheit äh und so haben wir jetzt,
Zusammenschnitt für sich viele Leute aus dem CCC Mühe gemacht haben den auf die Beine zu stellen wo also viele.
Ich glaub irgendwie über 40 oder was Leute Grußbotschaften an den CCC verfasst haben, einige,
äußerst kreativ, andere einfach zu Hause sitzend äh ihren ihre Gefühle oder ihre Wahrnehmung mal geäußert und ein Gruß in die Community losgeworden,
ähm übrigens auch mit nochmal mit einem Interview mit Steffen, der ja einer, der,
frühen und prägenden eine der frühen und prägenden Figuren des CCC war die auf jeden Fall den Club in einer Weise geprägt und verändert haben, auch ne nach der
nach der äh Gründung Steffen Weier bei dem
BTX-Heckfeder führend ähm hat unterschiedliche Abenteuer,
der Polizei erlebt, war in Frankreich im Knast und hat äh also wirklich ein ein sehr wildes äh Leben da gehabt, der hat aber dann auch sich glaube auch so ungefähr vor zwanzig Jahren, wenn nicht länger,
aus dem aktiven Geschehen ein bisschen zurückgezogen, sprich da auch äh öfter drüber, ne. Es waren dann halt die Todesfälle, die ihn da auch,
beschäftigt haben.
Und das ist schon äh sehr äh ich glaube sehr, sehr, sehr nett zu sehen für Leute, die den CCC kennen. An einigen Stellen wahrscheinlich ziemlich wo jetzt zu sehen für Leute, die den die den CCC nicht so kennen,
weil es eben eine sehr, sehr bunte Mischung ist, wie es der CCC eben.
Ist. Ähm keine Ahnung, ob wir dieses Jahr die Gelegenheit haben werden, nochmal,
uns in alter Frische und in alter,
Umgebung in altem Umfang zu sehen, da wird es sicherlich äh oder dafür werden natürlich nach wie vor Erwägungen und Diskussionen zu, aber das sind eben natürlich auch jetzt immer noch Unwegbarkeiten.
Mit denen wir da agieren müssen. Insgesamt glaube ich, können wir über diesen vierzigsten
nicht unglücklich sein, weil mit dem Film, den du ja gerade auch schon erwähnt hast, alles ist eins, seid wirklich ein großartiges Geschenk äh an den Club gemacht wurde und alle, die den noch nicht gesehen haben, sollten die Gelegenheit nutzen, wenn sie nirgendwo im Kino schauen können oder eben bis zum Winter warten,
auf das äh äh auf das Kaufrelease in DVD oder was auch immer das dann erscheinen wird,
Und ja, so war dann 40 Jahre CCC äh eine,
denkwürdige Veranstaltungen, die auch 20 Jahre später natürlich noch überschattet wird vom vom Nine Eleven gedenken, ne? Das werden wir jetzt immer bei den bei den runden Geburtstagen haben.
Aber ich denke, man kann auch eins sagen, auf das mich eine Freundin kürzlich hinwies, zwanzig dreiundzwanzig.
Zweiundvierzig.
Dann ist auch wieder Camp-Zeit.
Da wollen wir mal gucken. Wollen wir mal gucken in welchen in welches Stadium der Pandemie uns die Impferweiger bis dahin katapultiert.
So
Alle mal gepflegt gehackt legen wollte ich an dieser Gelegenheit bei dieser Gelegenheit nochmal sagen. Ich habe heute Morgen im äh Radio äh Deutschlandfunk der Tag oder was das war. Hm gehört ähm.
Das ist wohl um zwischen 5 und zehn Prozent der deutschen Bevölkerung sind, die sich im Laufe einer tödlichen Pandemie ernsthaft
weigern sich impfen zu lassen
Und ich, mir fällt zu euch Vollidioten echt gar nichts mehr ein, ne. Aber es ist wirklich dramatisch und dann fiel mir ein, dass irgendwie in ein paar Tagen Bundestagswahl ist, da fand ich das noch viel dramatischer. Und falls jetzt noch irgendeiner von euch Spinnern zuhört,
Denkt mal bitte für eine Mark mit. Ha! So, das wollte ich auch nochmal ganz kurz loswerden.
Ich denke, man muss jetzt einfach wirklich, also ich habe ja auch hier mehrere Phasen durchlaufen, ne, anfangs äh nein, anfangs bin ich überhaupt gar nicht davon ausgegangen,
dass es ähm Leute geben würde, die sich ernsthaft dieser Impfung widersetzen würden, also in in einem nennenswerten Ausmaß, ja? Ähm.
Natürlich war mir klar, dass es Impfpass,
fälschwillige geben würde und ein paar fällig Hirn verbrannte, die sich so nah Impfung dann auch meinen äh ernsthaft und aktiv widersetzen zu müssen, ne. Das hast du ja auch bei anderen Krankheiten,
Masern und fast nicht alles, ja. Aber das, dass diese Spinner für uns zum Problem werden würden, ähm damit habe ich,
nicht gerechnet. Ich habe eigentlich immer gedacht, dass wir uns, dass wir es, dass wir als Gesellschaft äh resilient genug sind, um uns einen kleinen Anteil von Vollidioten,
leisten zu können, auch einfach wenn's nur zum Belustigung ist, ja? Ähm aber,
in der Pandemie eben nicht so. Das positive ist, dass es war diese Ergebnis dieser Studie, dass jetzt von den bisher noch nicht geimpft.
Ist eben doch noch ein Anteil gibt an Menschen, die die halt einfach mal noch brauchen, die also nicht prinzipiell äh im Verweiger die Impfung verweigern, sondern eher so,
sagen wir mal ähm ja denen hat immer noch nicht die Attraktivitätsschwelle erreicht hat,
sich gegen eine potentiell tödliche Krankheit zu impfen. Das hat denen noch nicht,
noch nicht genug, die brauchen halt jetzt noch eine Bratwurst oder so eine ähm wie heißt das jetzt hier, so eine machen sie jetzt auch wieder, ne, Los Wochos. Bei der Impfung sind ja jetzt Los Wochos. Kennst du Tim?
Ich habe davon gehört.
Ja, das war als ich doch Fernsehen gucken konnte und geguckt habe, weil's einen gab im Haushalt, ey. Oder vielleicht geht's auch immer noch los.
Äh genau, jetzt bei beim Impfen sind Hits Wochos. Jetzt soll überall noch mal mehr geimpft werden. Das heißt, die Impfung geht jetzt zu den Menschen. Aber ich äh ich merke gerade, ich äh weiche schon wieder ab, ne.
Vom Thema 40 Jahre CCC auf jeden Fall auch,
äh ganz bei dir äh äh bin, also macht einen natürlich auch ein bisschen sauer, dass einem äh all diese ganzen kulturellen Elemente dann eben auch durch durch solche Leute einfach genommen werden. Ich bin da auch ganz bei dir. Ich äh
Ein Verständnis dafür ist auch null. So, ich habe da überhaupt gar keinerlei ähm,
Verständnis für für diese Haltung. Ich denke, die Informationen sind irgendwie klar. Sicherlich gibt's Leute, die sind einfach falsch informiert.
Und glauben das halt und so weiter. Okay, gut, ja, das äh ist dann wahrscheinlich auch so. Aber ähm,
Muss ich mich dann eben trotzdem nicht unbedingt jetzt auch äh so positiv dann zu gegenüber einstellen. Also das ist halt einfach mal das.
Geht so nicht und es ist einfach eine eine Frechheit, gegenüber äh dem Rest der Gesellschaft. Und das muss ein Ende finden.
Also danke, dass ihr uns den Geburtstag verhagelt habt. Nein, seid ja nicht nur ihr Schuld, aber äh doch, eigentlich schon. Dann äh kommen wir mal wieder zu unseren Kernthemen, nämlich der Netzpolitik.
Ja, zwar haben wir hier ja vor in den letzten Sendungen immer wieder auch über NSO,
Pegasus gesprochen, also ein für seine Fähigkeiten der breitflächigen Infektion bekannter,
Staatstrojaner für Mobiltelefone, der vor einigen Wochen.
Analysiert wurde, äh mal wieder, wo es jetzt ein Detection Tool gibt, was das äh was äh Indicateres of Compromis aus,
den iPhone Backups erkennen kann und der ähm ja über eine iMessage Schwachstelle offenbar auf die Geräte gelangte und dort keine dauerhafte Persistenz hatte,
also wenn das Gerät neu gestartet wurde wieder verschwand. Was eben eine relativ gute Möglichkeit ist, eine einer Detektion auch zu entkommen, wenngleich die das mit Sicherheit nicht absichtlich gemacht haben, sondern,
ihre Fähigkeit neben die spezifischen Gegebenheiten ihnen keine Persistenz erlaubten, sondern durch ein.
Ähm spezifische Speicher Miss Handling im Zweifelsfall eben eine,
temporärer, aber keine dauerhafte Kompromitierung des Gerätes ermöglichte. So.
In dieser Angelegenheit gibt es äh zwei Neuigkeiten. Also auffällig geworden war dieses Unternehmen, das muss man vielleicht noch sagen, weil es eine Liste potenzieller Ziele mit mehr als 50.000 Telefonnummern gab
ähm darunter Menschenrechtsaktivistin, Journalistinnen, Rechtsanwältinnen, ähm,
und auch Staats- und Regierungschefs,
Ministerinnen und hochrangige Diplomatinnen. Also man sieht hier spezifisch bei der Nutzung dieser Software,
dass sie eben nicht in der beworben in dem beworbenen Bereich der Strafverfolgung eingesetzt wird, sondern eben im Bereich der,
geheim Spionage und Machtpolitik und im Kampf gegen Freiheitskämpferinnen im eigenen Lande
So und dieses Unternehmen.
NSO rühmt sich natürlich nur äh nach strengen äh Exportrestriktionen zu handeln und ne, irgendwie
im Zweifelsfall dann der eigene moralische Wächter über die Kundinnen zu sein, alles natürlich Unsinn, wissen wir auch und das,
das Einzige, was man halt machen kann, ist zu versuchen, diese Unternehmen mit allen Methoden zu bekämpfen und zu ächten,
dachte sich natürlich auch, die Bundesrepublik Deutschland, die ja bisher so weit man weiß, nur mit dem ebenso zu verachtenden Unternehmen Gamma,
Finn Fischer unter oder dem Unternehmenskonglumerat, Kammer, Finn Fischer,
zusammengearbeitet hat. Das, ja, Ziel von Ermittlungen ist,
im Rahmen der Export dem des Umgehens von Exportrestriktionen und deren Androidstaatstrojaner äh in vielen Versionen, Torsten Schröder und ich ja.
Zwanzig neunzehn, glaube ich, analysiert hatten. Dachten wir, jetzt stellt sich raus,
im Jahr 2017 hat das PKA erstmals mit NSO verhandelt und sich die Fähigkeiten von Pegasus vorführen lassen
haben sich dafür extra eine Delegation äh aus Israel einreisen lassen und äh mussten dann
musste dann aber einsehen, dass Juristen gesagt haben, pass mal auf, denn das äh bei diesen Fähigkeiten dieser Software äh ist es relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass das verfassungsgemäß ist, ja? Weil
man übernimmt das komplette Telefon, die Sachen werden bei werden,
äh im Zweifelsfall durch NS O Pegasus vorgenommen. Ja, man hat hier also so ein Intermediär noch mit drin. Und das ist äh kommt eben dem juristischen Konstrukt der Onlinedurchsuchung äh gleich, die nur in besonders schwer gelagerten Fällen,
ähm.
Ja zulässig ist, was das BKA ja sucht, ist eine oder primär sucht ist eine Lösung zur Quellen, Telekommunikationsüberwachung, ein juristisches Konstrukt, bei dem davon ausgegangen wird, dass eben nur,
die Echtzeit-Kommunikation des äh Telefones übernommen wird. So, dann hat das BKA,
sich gesagt naja OK da müssen wir versuchen selber hinkriegen oder so haben aber nicht wirklich was hinbekommen und haben dann ab Ende 219 sie sich dann Handels einig geworden mit NSO.
Ja? Äh und haben gesagt, ja, schaltet
irgendwie schränkt man den Funktionsumfang ein, damit sich äh damit Viecher mit den juristischen Vorgaben des Bundesverfassungsgerichts irgendwie sagen können, dass wir uns bemühen, damit
arbeiten.
Die Bundesregierung wurde explizit gefragt, ob Bundesbehörden NSA-Software einsetzen, 20019 von Martina Renner, dem hat sie gerade schon erwähnt, vom deutschen Journalistenverband ähm und in diesem Jahr,
in einer kleinen Anfrage der Bundestagsfraktion der Grünen. In allen Fällen hat das Inministerium geantwortet, dass man auf diese Frage keinerlei Auskunft erteile.
Und es wird jetzt irgendwie kolportiert, dass BKA habe eventuell diese,
Sache gekauft oder diesen Vertrag unterzeichnet.
Ohne dass äh das Innenministerium, also Horst Seehofer, davon wusste, ja äh das lese ich noch nicht mal zu Ende, weil ich ist absolut nicht vorstellbar, dass das äh,
Also so ein Vertrag, der wird teuer genug sein und dass irgendjemand hingeht und das macht ohne äh eben im im Innenministerium Leuten Bescheid zu sagen, halte ich für absolut unglaubwürdig?
Absolut unglaubwürdig, aber auch eine äh eine wahrscheinlich übliche Strategie quasi, dass man eben zu so etwas nicht,
offiziell sagt, äh mach das, sonst haben wir hier einen Paper, den nachher irgendjemand anfragen kann und dann müssen wir nachher auf Anfragen, die wir erhalten, ehrlich antworten. Also äh,
Schaffen wir euch mal irgendwie grundsätzlich die Möglichkeit, dass ihr selbstständig darüber entscheiden dürft, damit ihr uns nicht äh informieren,
dürft, ja? Ist aber in meinen Augen absoluter Wahnsinn, wenn man äh dem BKA diese dieses Recht ein einräumt, potenziell hier äh
ich sage mal, ganz bewusst äh Unrechts- und Terrorsoftware einzukaufen.
Und damit äh die Entwicklung solcher Software zu unterstützen, die ja spezifisch nur deshalb so gut ist und aus nur nur deshalb so gut ist,
weil sie Sicherheitslücken auf iPhones und Android-Geräten geheim halten, ja? Es ist überhaupt nicht schwierig, einen äh einen Staatstrojaner zu schreiben, überhaupt,
ja? Es ist nur schwierig, die Zielgeräte zu infizieren, noch dazu,
auf eine Weise, dass es die Zielperson vielleicht noch nicht mal merken, also durch technische,
Remote Code Execution Explod. Das ist der schwierige Teil und der schwierige, dieser schwierige Teil funktioniert nur dann, wenn die Schwachstellen auf allen Systemen sind. Und das ist etwas, was wir auch
immer gepredigt haben. Meine letzte war es meine letzte Auskunft im im,
im Innenausschuss zu Staatstrojane. Es spezifisch das nochmal alles erklärt, wer infizieren will, braucht Schwachstellen. Wir haben es immer wieder geleugnet, ja? Und jetzt merkt man, auf welche lustigen Ebene dir das leugnen, ne, dass man irgendwie sagt so, ihr braucht Schwachstellen, dann sagen die, nein, brauchen wir nicht.
Ihr nicht, die Jacke,
jemand anders kennt ihr, die geben euch die noch nicht mal, sondern lassen euch die Mieten, ja? Was äh ohne ohne sie euch zu verraten. Also es ist wirklich.
Eine Katastrophe und da kannst du dir auch jetzt schon vorstellen, wie das dann weitergeht, ne? Dass du dann nämlich demnächst sagen.
Wir können ja nur noch Staatstrianer äh ähm von Drittanbietern nehmen, wo die, wo die, wo wir die Schwachstellen, wie sie auf die Geräte lang nicht nicht selber kennen, sonst müssten wir diese Schwachstellen ja melden, weil's ein äh,
prozess gibt oder sowas, ne? Also das ist.
Wie wie ekelig sind diese Leute, ja? Und wie berat und und wie offensichtlich verstoßen die.
Und gezielt verstoßen die gegen den guten Geschmack und gegen demokratische Prinzipien und gegen äh die Schutzziele unserer,
eigenen inneren Sicherheit, die wir immer wieder anmahnen. Das ist wirklich äh sehr, sehr, sehr frustrierend und gleichzeitig überhaupt keine Überraschung.
So, dann.
War allerdings immer wieder ein Rätsel. Wie kommt denn eigentlich also es es war irgendwie ungefähr klar, dass der dass dieser Angriff.
Funktioniert durch ähm.
Messages. Also zumindest wenn er sich gegen iPhones richtet. Also eine geht an äh bei einem Telefon ein,
wird dort verarbeitet. Das ist eine relativ.
Also man man vermutet erstmal eine relativ geringe Angriffsfläche, weil vielleicht ja nur ein Text äh gerändert werden muss. Jetzt können aber natürlich auch äh Grafiken darstellen und,
PDFs darstellen. Und ähm.
Jetzt ist heute, am 13. September, iOS vierzehn Punkt acht und iPad US vierzehn Punkt acht erschienen, in dem eine,
Schwachstelle in Chor Graphics und in Webkit gefixt wird, dem Browser, Ränderer, ja, wo sie sagen.
Okay, ein bösartig verändertes PDF konnte zur Record Execution führen. Apple weiß,
dass äh wer weiß von einem Bericht, dass diese Schwachstelle aktiv ausgenutzt.
Geworden, Gesang gekonnt gehabt hätte würden. Ähm sagen also ein wurde adressiert,
ähm durch äh verbesserte Input Velidation. Und dieses CWE zwanzig einundzwanzig dreißig,
achtsechzig, also die dreißigtausendachthundertsechzigstes CWI von zwanzig einundzwanzig, CVEs sind die und.
Quasi so der der Jahreskatalog der Schwachstellen, wurde gemeldet von äh The Citizon Lab, unseren Freunden in,
Kanada, die tatsächlich diesen nennen,
und sagen, dass er mindestens seit Februar 21 im Einsatz war. Ähm.
Auch hier wieder, ne, eine universitäre Forschungsgruppe, eine ural Algisa,
also,
ist der Prof, der diese äh Gruppe, das das Citizen.
An der University seit vielen Jahren,
leitet, ja? Das sind so, ich meine, das ist das Level von Leuten, die.
Oder mit diesen Ressourcen sehr eingeschränkten Ressourcen und guten.
Müssen dann diese Schwachstellen irgendwie erforschen.
Äh melden an an Apple, weil irgendwo Unternehmen viele Millionen macht damit diese Schwachstellen geheim zu halten und somit einem die die Sicherheit von,
hundert äh von von hunderten Millionen Geräten äh ähm schwächt,
von einem Konzern, der, glaube ich, immer noch der weltweit wertvollste Konzern ist ähm hergestellt werden, ja? Und da müssen irgendwie ein paar äh IT Security Forscher mit einem,
zu diesem Thema und zu gesellschaftlicher Verantwortung, die müssen diese Schwachstellen am Ende fixen und melden, ja? Äh erforschen,
und melden, damit sie gefixt werden können.
Es ist wirklich äh krass, ne? Und jetzt willst du also iPhones aufm iPhone willst du iOS vierzehn acht haben? Ähm.
Mac willst du aus XXR elf Punkt sechs äh oder Security-Update zwanzig einundzwanzig null fünf Katarina haben und äh auf der Apple Watch willst du, willst du Apple Watch, US7,
sechs zwei haben. Ja, weil Apple diese ähm Schwachstelle direkt.
In all diesen Geräten hat in dieser,
Datenbank. In dem gleichen Update wird noch eine andere Schwachstelle äh gefixt, die äh wie ich gerade schon sagte, äh Webkit berührt, also Webkit ist der Ränderer für,
Websites, also da wird einfach nur gesagt also irgendeine Art von.
Webseite oder Webinar. Sie haben nicht spezifisch gesagt, welcher kann eben zur Code Execution führen und auch da gehen sie davon aus, dass das äh aktiv ausgenutzt wurde. Das ist also eine Schwachstelle ähm,
in der äh die die äh getriggert werden kann beim Besuchen einer Webseite und das war in äh Use after free.
Und da haben sie jetzt im Proof Memory Management. Sehr schön, offenbar benutzen die.
Immer noch nicht überall speichersichere Sprachen für ihren komischen Webketbrowser, aber gut, wer wer macht das schon?
Na ja, weil ist ja genau, wer macht denn das schon, ne? Ich meine, diese ganzen Dateiformate, für all diese ganzen Bildformate, die sich permanent weiterentwickeln, das ist natürlich auch ein Höllenritz, ne
was da nicht alles unter unterschieden werden muss, das ist jetzt hier PDF betrifft.
Jetzt grade gar nicht, aber überrascht natürlich auch nicht, weil PDF natürlich an sich auch schon eine ganze Menge Komplexität hat. Ist ja auch nur so ein Strukturformat, in dem dann wieder andere Bilder drin sind und dann kann hier noch ein Tiff und da noch ein JPAG und hier noch ein BNG drin sein. Und
diese ganzen komplizierten binären Dateiformate
nur ein Bit nicht richtig sitzt, so so wie man's erwartet hat, dann kann halt äh Code, der irgendwie erstmal eigentlich,
immer vom Besten ausgeht, ja, der wird dann sozusagen so von so einem Trickbetrüger äh erwischt und macht dann halt einfach was äh anderes,
es ist halt nicht alle Eigenschaften aller Bildformate nochmal in allen sicheren Promiersprachen komplett neu programmiert worden,
auch permanent äh.
Weiterentwickeln müsste. Wäre schön, aber ist halt einfach nicht die Realität. Und so laufen wir halt immer wieder in diese Probleme rein, die ja durch Entscheidungen, die vielleicht vor 30 Jahren schon gefällt wurden, äh.
Immer wieder so zum Problem werden.
Ja, war ähm News after free hat nicht unbedingt was mit dem Detailformat zu tun. Es ist immer noch ein Programmierfehler, ne?
Sind alles, es sind alles,
Fehler, aber es äh äh der Code liegt halt nur in Sprachen vor, die eben all diese ganzen Safegards, die man heutzutage gerne haben möchte, wo sowas gar nicht erst passieren kann,
äh wo dieser ganze Speicher nicht von Hand verwaltet wird, äh ja, existiert halt einfach äh noch nicht so umfänglich, wie man's gerne hätte.
Keine Entschuldigung, ist nur eine Erklärung, warum das überhaupt noch passiert.
Offenbar, also wahrscheinlich,
hat das einfach hinbekommen oder oder war haben sie, weil sie ja im guten Kontakt zu Leuten stehen,
die ähm.
Zu, die zum Beispiel sich irgendwie in Saudi-Arabien äh unbeliebt gemacht haben und somit dann erstaunlich häufig äh,
Pegasus Spyware auf Ihrem Telefon haben und äh Sie sagen, also es gibt einen anonymen Aktivisten, wo Sie dann eben mal ein
iTunes Backup hatten, ja? Und dann haben sie das Backup wieder analysiert und haben verschiedene,
Giftpfalz im Folder Library SMS-Etaggements gefunden. Ähm und dann konnten sie eben sehen, okay, diese, die wo diese GIFs wurden empfangen.
Kurz bevor das Telefon eben kompromittiert wurde.
Und so sind sie dann eben an die Stelle an die Stelle gekommen, dass sie einen funktionierenden Exploit hatten und wenn du das Ding hast, klar, dann ist es nicht mehr schwer, äh den zu analysieren und zu gucken, was genau wohl,
schiefgeht, ja? Und das ist hier genau erklärt, dass es,
zwar eine Gif äh Extension hatte, aber in Wirklichkeit PSD-Fall war und äh wie dann irgendwie diese,
Library aus dem, aus dem Tritt gebracht wurde, ja? Krasse Geschichte, Wahnsinns Research, wie gesagt,
sehr stark vereinfacht dadurch, dass du ähm.
Das sollten funktionierenden Exploit vor dir hast und den durch durch saubere Recherche gefunden hast und das dann an Apple äh zu melden ist natürlich,
muss man sich nicht kleinreden und äh das könnt ihr auch alle wirklich sehr stolz drauf sein, dass sie das gemacht haben, weil das wird jetzt, ne, hoffentlich,
ist es eben ein Kopf, den man äh der Hüdra abgeschlagen hat, NSO, Pegasus werden wahrscheinlich die ganze Zeit nur daran forschen oder die NSU wird nur daran forschen,
neue Zero CliqueX zu finden, haben wahrscheinlich auch einige auf Halde, aber ähm immerhin ist das jetzt mal eine äh weniger.
Kommen wir äh zur deutschen, strategischen Reaktion darauf. Man hat jetzt eine Cyber-Sicherheitsstrategie noch verabschiedet. Ich meine,
Seehofer ist ja echt auch so ein so ein auf den Tisch,
alter Mann, ne? Der geht jetzt in Ruhestand, jetzt muss der noch ähm noch irgendwie eine Strategie für,
definieren für sein Amt. Also ich weiß warum eigentlich, ja? Also,
für die nächsten fünf Jahre will er jetzt eine Strategie festlegen, also kann er nur hoffen,
dass wir nicht einen Innenminister bekommen, der meint irgendwie in die ähm in die Fußstapfen von Seehofer treten zu müssen.
Noch schlimmer Seehofer selbst noch mal?
Nee, nee, der hat angekündigt, der will jetzt endlich in Ruhestand.
Aber wir haben äh, also es gibt ja einen schönen Kommentar von Jakob, von Lindern, Aufzeit online, äh der nämlich auch sehr, sehr klar sagt, ja, äh.
Damit macht die vermeintliche Sicherheitsstrategie das Ganze internet unsicherer. Weil was wollen sie machen? Sie sagen, ja, Verschlüsselung finden wir super, aber.
Wir wollen sie brechen. Wir wollen sie umgehen können. Wir wollen Schwachstellen nutzen. Äh wir wollen ähm Geräte kompromittieren und wir wollen.
Technische und operative Lösungen für den rechtmäßigen Zugang zu Inhalten aus verschlüsselter Kommunikation,
zu rechtmäßigen Zugang, ne? Das ist ja auch echt geil, ne? Verschlüsselte Kommunikation wollen wir echt haben, aber wir brauchen einen rechtmäßigen Zugang dazu, ja. Ähm.
Damit ist relativ klar und das benennen sie auch. Sie sagen, ja, das ist ja nicht so schön. Also wir haben ja diese Quellen-TKÜ, aber ähm.
Aufgrund der technischen und operativen Herausforderung in der Praxis ist das ja auf Einzelfälle beschränkt. Das geht ja nicht.
Das ist auf Einzelfälle beschränkt und so, wenn wir Geräte hacken und das soll ja wohl bitte aus dem Einzelfall, soll ja bitte die Regel werden, spezifischer Grund, ja und dann.
Entscheiden die jetzt in ihrem Kabinett gut zwei Wochen vor der Bundestagswahl diese Strategie ja in der übrigens auch noch.
Gesagt wird, wir möchten ähm einen Heckbag machen. Und ich habe das hier auch schon hundert Mal äh ähm erklärt, ne, dass also,
Das, was die als Hackpack meinen, ist, was sie mit meinen, ist nicht das, was sie erzählen, äh die erzählen, wir wollen,
gegen die Ursachen schwerer Cyber-Angriffe aktiv vorgehen. Und es gibt dann immer auf immer findest du irgend so 'n.
Irgend so 'n Polizisten oder oder irgend so 'n sonstigen Schreibtischtäter ohne, ohne Keyboard, der dann irgendwie erzählt, er würde 'ne aktive Angriffe könnten ja,
äh ab, ne? Da gibt's jetzt einen Digidos aufm Krankenhaus,
und und deswegen sterben die Leute und dann will man aber jetzt aktiv den den Angreifer hacken, damit der Angriff aufhält, ne? Sind so völlig hanebüchende Geschichten, weil,
Angriff auf ein Krankenhaus sicherlich nicht zu einem Ausfall der Geräte führen könnte. Und ein Hack des Angreifers sicherlich nicht den Detox angestoppt,
Es geht nicht um irgendwie akutes Zurückhaken. Es geht um.
Mindestens taktisches, wenn ich strategisches hacken und mit Sicherheit kann man das oder mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit kann man das einfach juristisch nicht so definieren, dass es tatsächlich für die Abwehr,
laufender Gefahren stattfindet, sondern die werden sich natürlich für die generelle ähm.
Das generelle Vorgehen gegen Gefahren den Freischein holen und der beinhaltet dann eben generell die Lizenz zum Hacking. So und wenn sie die mit dem ersten Mal nicht kriegen, dann holen sie sich die mit Sicherheit mit einem zweiten Mal. Und.
Das wiederum wird wieder dazu führen, ne, niemand hackt spontan irgendetwas.
Es geht immer dabei um die Suche nach Schwachstellen. Du kannst Glück haben bei neuer selbst entwickelter Software von irgendjemandem, dass du da Schwachstellen drin findest, aber die wahrscheinlichere Lösung ist, dass du in in Librarys,
verwendet werden in äh alten Versionen, die verwendet werden, bekannte
also Schwachstellen sammelst und bei bei ähm.
Bei gegebenem Anlass dann ausnutzt, ja, dass du einfach eine Sammlung an Schwachstellen hast, in möglichst verbreiteten Systemen, um deine Wahrscheinlichkeit zu steigern, dass du die Schwachstellen,
auch ausnutzen kannst. Und.
So machen es auch die anderen Geheimdienste, die offensiv unterwegs sind und die Konsequenzen davon kennen wir die Konsequenzen davon sind so etwas wie äh die Schwachstätte äh geführt hat,
katastrophalem Ausmaß, die,
Cyberschadensfälle, wie es mal so nennen darf, die äh als die schwersten und teuersten bisher gelten. Und
Das ist genau das Risiko, was da eingegangen wird. Ja, das geht in einem Vortier. Wir reden seit drei Themen über das Gleiche, ja. Unterstützung von aktiver Unterstützung von,
Unsicherheit statt dem Gegenteil. Warum? Dachte, die wären für die innere Sicherheit zuständig.
Tja, das haben sie aber sehen sie aber irgendwie anders.
Wie, was wir davon haben, sehen wir ja jetzt. Unsere, unser BKA äh unterstützt irgendwelche moralisch komplett bankrotten.
Unternehmen, die den Saudis dabei helfen, andere Leute zu töten. Er heißt doch wirklich, es ist doch, das ist doch nicht mehr schön.
So ist es mit unserer ausgehenden Regierung.
Hoffen wir mal, dass diese, dass sie trotzdem noch versauert, weil ähm,
sämtliche Expertinnen, sämtliche Forscherinnen, sogar der wissenschaftliche Dienst des Bundestags hat sich dagegen ausgesprochen, alle Parteien im Bundestag vertretenen Parteien sprechen sich dagegen aus, werden wir mal sehen, also es ist wahrscheinlich auch einerseits der Grund, warum der Seehofer das jetzt nur irgendwie durchprügeln will
ähm aber äh auch sehr schön kommentiert hier, wenn sich die Umfragewerte der Union nicht noch dramatisch erhöhen,
nach der Wahl wohl keine Mehrheit für solchen Unsinn geben. Und das äh ist jetzt natürlich auch wieder die Hoffnung, ne, sorgt einfach dafür, dass es nach der Wahl,
keinen Mehrheit für derartigen Unsinn gibt und das könnt ihr am ehesten hinkriegen, indem ihr keine Nazis und keine Christdemokraten wählt.
Wofür es aber im Bundestag eine Mehrheit gab, Tim Broadcast.
Ist so lustig, wie wir hier nach diesem Wahltag gesagt haben, warum macht man das nicht mit? Dann ist, dann passiert noch die Flut in NRW übrigens,
soll ich sagen, Tim, weißt du, wer in NRW Ministerpräsident ist? Also, lässt das Amt eigentlich seit einem Jahr ruhen, weil er im Wahlkampf ist?
Ja. Ist das nicht dieser Laschet.
Kanzlerkandidat, Kanzlerkandidat der CDU. Hm.
Aber ja, jetzt haben sie, jetzt haben sie nachdem das das nachdem da das Land unter Wasser war, haben sie jetzt entschieden, dass sie,
also eine gesetzliche Regelung für Broadcasts suchen
und äh jetzt müssen deutsche Netzwerker das installieren, rechte Basis und so wird es geben und äh zuständig für das Abfassen der Warnung werden dann,
Behörden zur Gefahrenabwehr und für Zivil- und Katastrophenschutz, da soll dann eine TKG-Änderung stattfinden,
ähm und na ja, dann äh sollen,
auch Nummern, gebundene Messenger, wie Signal und WhatsApp in notwendigem Umfang daran mitwirken, dass die Warnungen zeitnah zugestellt werden. Da merkst du auch wieder, ey Leute, ihr habt das ihr habt das nicht verstanden, was der Broadcast ist, so. Ihr habt es echt nicht verstanden.
Das nicht. Verstanden. Das ist wirklich, die haben es nicht verstanden, Tim. Die haben's in 20 Jahren nicht verstanden.
Es geht ja nicht nur um es geht ja auch sozusagen auch um die Distribution dieser,
Warnmeldung, dass sie dann halt bei manchen WhatsApps und so weiter nicht ankommen werden, geschenkt. Ja, aber es ist ja trotzdem sinnvoll, solche Messengersysteme äh an an so etwas auch anzuschließen.
Ist es nicht, aber lassen wir das. Dann dann kannst du von mir aus, dann kriegst du die Nachricht halt zweimal, weil gegen Broadcast wirst du dich auch nicht wehren können,
und,
und die Idee an Broadcast ist doch die räumliche Konzentration, ja? Und solche GPS für Signal freigeben, der mit Signal irgendwo zentral gucken kann, ob die Bundesregierung grade eine Broadcast-Nachricht für mich hat,
bekommen habe, wenn ich in der Zelle bin.
Ja, aber das Problem ist doch, dass die Impfgegner äh die glauben, dass ja erst, wenn's auf Telegram kommt.
Ja gut, das wäre vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlecht, da mal der Evolution freien Lauf zu lassen.
Ich hatte befürchtet, dass du das sagen wirst.
Oh je.
Apropos Schwabler und ihre Kanäle. Atila, dein Freund Attila. Der hat äh seinen Kanal eingebüßt. Ja.
Ja, der wurde eben, der hat den falschen Leuten vertraut, ne.
Ja, na ja, der hat überhaupt Leuten vertraut und hat's halt, sagen wir mal, äh
so auch überrissen, glaube ich, dass mit dass dass jetzt auch wirklich der letzte noch begriffen hat, dass mit ihm kein Staat so machen ist. Wenn ich das richtig sehe, hat irgendwie sein äh Admin,
Ist jetzt irgendwie übergelaufen und äh letzten Endes landeten wohl so
Die Credentials für seine äh Kanäle oder für sein Telegram-Account, ich weiß es nicht genau, landeten bei irgendeiner,
Truppe, die sich jetzt mal wieder unter diesem Anonnimus äh gemeldet hat, da weiß man ja immer nicht so, wer das jetzt gerade ist. Es gibt ja bei muss immer so den Member Djur, ja, also ob's da in irgendeiner Form irgendeine Kontinuität
äh lässt sich nicht beantworten, sondern es kann auch einfach sein, dass es jede Woche äh eine ganz andere Gruppe ist, die sich halt so nennt. Aber halt so Leute im im im Netz, die äh,
bisschen was von Computern äh äh verstehen, haben sich wohl dieser Kredenz angenommen und haben irgendwie seine Kanäle dicht gemacht, übernommen.
Äh die waren wohl eh schon ziemlich äh zusammengeschrumpft auf,
mittlerweile fünfstellige äh Subscriber äh Zahlen, nachdem wir's ja immer irgendwie im Millionenbereich geschafft hat, zur Hochzeit dieses ganzen Wahnsinns.
Und mittlerweile hat er sich ja auch kleinlaut irgendwo in der Türkei äh verkrochen und gibt nicht mehr viel von sich. Ab und zu hat er wohl noch so ein paar kleinere Kanäle, wo er rumjammert und seine Verschwörungs
Geschichten,
packt, aber jetzt ist wohl so richtig vorbei und wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist in dem Zuge, ist er jetzt auch noch seiner ganzen Domains, äh seine ganzen Domains sind auch noch abhanden gekommen über diese.
Ja, die haben's ihm auch weggenommen.
So
Also die Geschichte kurz gefasst ist, dass es da einen ähm einen Admin gibt äh von der für Attila Hildmann.
Diese ganzen Zugänge verwaltet hat und ähm.
Im Prinzip auch alles, was der redet, glaubt, solange es irgendwie um äh Impfverweigerung und Pandemie und äh sonstigen Kram ging.
Aber ähm nicht ähm mit dessen Rechtsradikalität,
im in Übereinstimmung ist, ja? Also dass er äh dass er eben ein Nazi ist, der mit Hakenkreuzen Nationalsozialismus und sonstigen Dingern äh,
agiert. Und als er ein altes Handy von Attila als Arbeitshandy einrichtete, habe er eben festgestellt,
Zitat, dass seine ganzen Bilder von vor drei Jahren schon irgendwie so eine Nazischeiße sind, ja? Und dann hat sich dieser Admin eben dazu entschieden.
Naja, den um den echt einen auszuwischen und hat ihn dann eben, hat immer mehr um sein äh Vertrauen geworben und ihn dann am Ende dazu gebracht, auch zum Beispiel Domains sicherheitshalber in ihn.
Zu transferieren.
DE und dann irgendwie ganz viel mit,
ich weiß nicht genau, was das ist. Habe ich mich so viel mit auseinandergesetzt, aber Demos und wir machen auf und Attila Hildmann Forum, allen möglichen Scheiß
Aha-Forum Punkt org. Er hat sich echt noch mit den Initialen noch irgendwie in Aha-Forum gemacht. Na ja
die jetzt alle auf äh die Facementpages von äh und auch eine Reihe an Telegram-Kanälen, in denen wir jetzt einfach gesagt, so übrigens, wir werden euch in Zukunft über auf dem Laufenden
halten. Jetzt haben, jetzt sagen sie, äh diese ganzen Inhalte, da haben sie natürlich jetzt relativ viel von dem, das wollen sie eben ähm.
Hier äh langsam äh veröffentlichen und äh diese Daten zur Auswertung übergeben. Bin mal gespannt, was da jetzt noch äh kommen wird,
Ähm und sie hoffen, dass es jetzt äh.
Behörde geben wird, die vielleicht doch die Dringlichkeit und Notwendigkeit begreift und all diese Daten überblicken kann. Nee, das hoffen sie nicht. Sie glauben nicht daran und leider stimmen sie dazu, ja.
Tja, schade, äh dass das sich da eben die Polizei nicht drum gekümmert hat, ähm,
Linker sein müssen, dann wäre der Spaß längst ein ein Ende bereitet worden.
So ist es also, Attila Hildmann ergangen. Ähm ja, ich muss persönlich sagen.
Also schöner hätte ich's natürlich gefunden, wenn äh der Vogel einfach irgendwann seinen Einfluss vollständig verloren hätte und ihn auch alle als den Spinner.
Gesehen und wahrgenommen hätten, der er ist und jetzt ist es natürlich irgendwie, es sind schon drastische Maßnahmen, jemanden seiner Domains zu berauben und seiner seiner reichweitenstarken Telegramkanäle.
Gleichzeitig wenn ich mein selbst die, also wenn die Unterstützer aus dem engsten Kreis halt sagen nein das ist ein jemand der hier halt verfassungsfeindliche Inhalte verbreitet und dafür auch nicht vergessen der ja auch deswegen von der Polizei gesucht wird. Es gibt ja Haftbefehle
ja? Und ähm entsprechend sagen hier übrigens auch die von Enorm ist, dass sie,
oder diese Stellen in Aussicht, dass sie einen Beweis dafür haben, dass der erste Haftbefehl gegen hielt man an ihn durchgestochen wurde. Ja und das sind ja auch schon wieder so,
ganz, ganz üble Dinge, weil das wieder heißt, ne, dass wir in unserem äh Strafverfolgungssystem ähm.
Tja, irgendwelche Sympathisanten mit diesen äh mit diesen Nazi haben.
Ja und das ist schon alles äh schwierig. Und ist sehr, sehr schwierig.
Ja, aber jetzt hat's sich auf jeden Fall erst mal aus äh aus kanalisiert bei ihm. Ich glaube, von dem werden wir so schnell nichts mehr.
Ich bin mal gespannt, also ich weiß nicht, denke schon, dass er irgendwie über
also müsste man mal gucken, ob er nur recht, ob er diesem atmen technisch die Kontrolle über die Domains gegeben hat, dann sollte er eigentlich in der Lage sein, innerhalb von paar Tagen die für sich zurückzugewinnen
Ähm.
Wenn er die auch rechtlich übermittelt hat, dann wird er jetzt also wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schwieriger werden für ihn jetzt. Das ist mir da jetzt nicht äh nicht hundert Prozent drin äh erkenntlich,
was da der der genaue Hintergrund äh ist. Auf jeden Fall nicht so wird nicht ganz so einfach werden, ne? Aber also ob das jetzt dauerhaft ist, weiß ich nicht, aber gleichzeitig äh ähm
versuchen sich wahrscheinlich jetzt auch die Leute aus diesem Telegramkanal zurückzuziehen. Hm wenn sie wissen, dass der jetzt in den Händen von Enorm ist. Übrigens einer der Gründe,
warum ich da selbstverständlich mit irgendwelchen Fake-Accounts drin bin.
Drin gewesen bin, weil man einfach mit solchen Leuten nicht assoziiert werden möchte. So und jetzt kommt etwas ganz Ungewohntes für uns, Tim.
Ja, was denn.
Mal wieder ein äh Termin ankündigen.
Mit Musik.
Ich würd's mit Musik versuchen, einfach um der alten Tage Willen.
Datenspuren 2021 finden statt in Dresden.
18. und 19. September in Zentralwerk in der Riesastraße.
Und die Veranstaltung findet als Präsenzveranstaltung statt. Kommt bitte geimpft.
Nur geimpft. Macht bitte einen Selbsttest. Es gibt auch Selbsttest vor Ort.
Und ähm die in Veranstaltung ist in der Gesamtteilnehmerzahl eingeschränkt,
und man wird natürlich getracet, also benutzt bitte die Corona-Warn-App und checkt euch in die Veranstaltung ein. Bonus für jeden, der Luca heißt, gibt es zur Wiedergutmachung eine freie Mate an der Bar,
Ich denke, das dürfte Einladung genug sein und ich denke,
ihr werdet euch sicherlich erfreuen an dieser kleinen, aber sehr feinen Veranstaltung des Klubs Dresden.
Das ist sozusagen 1 einsG plus. Würde ich das nennen, diese Coronaregeln.
Eins G Plus. Ich finde eher, ist es nicht G-Quadrat? Geimpft, getestet.
Ist es halt, da ist halt eigentlich nur ein ein.
Nur geimpft sozusagen, das schließt ja auch Chinesen aus, wenn ich das richtig äh sehe, nach dem Motto, ihr solltet euch jetzt mal alle irgendwie geimpft haben so, aber der der Test kommt dann sozusagen noch zusätzlich oben drauf.
Hm, genesen indiskriminiert. Ich glaube nicht, dass die beabsichtigen, dass hier Genesene nicht also ich denke, dass äh.
Da steht nix davon, von Genesen. Das ist für mich 1 G und mit wenn man dann trotzdem nochmal testet, dann ist es für mich 1 G Plus.
Ach so, weil weil's nicht, weil's nicht oder verknüpft ist. Oder, oder ist.
Ja genau, ja weil's nicht äh impfen reicht, ne, so, wenn's halt äh,
testen lassen könnte, ohne dass man geimpft ist, dann wär's ja im Prinzip schon wieder die zwei, drei Griegel, je nachdem, wie man da mit den Genesenden noch umgeht. Also, ich nenne das jetzt mal eins G plus und ich.
Durchaus für zu haben.
Quadrat.
Okay, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall sind's die Datenspuren und äh schön, dass äh es stattfinden kann. Hast du schon gesagt, wo? Nee, ne?
Ja, doch, habe ich gesagt, im Zentralwerk in Dresden, in der Riesastraße.
Ja, dann äh könnt ihr da alle mal hingehen und das ist ja jetzt auch bald. Und bin froh, dass wir es den Termin jetzt noch endlich mal unterbekommen haben. Nachdem wir schon mehrfach auf die Finger bekommen haben, warum wir sie noch nicht gebracht haben.
Ja, das äh tut uns leid, dass dass er nicht da mit reingerutscht ist.
Ja, das war's, Tim. Ähm ich weiß nicht, ob's unsere letzte Sendung vor der Wahl ist, hatten wir, ich glaube, wir haben äh ausreichend empfohlen, zu wählen und auch ausreichend ausgedrückt, wen wir empfehlen, nicht zu wählen.
Auf jeden Fall, denke ich auch.
Und ähm jetzt heißt es Daumen drücken. Ich hatte mich ja übrigens für die Bundestagswahl als Wahlhelfer gemeldet, ne? Ich habe bisher immer noch keinen Einberufungsbescheid bekommen.
Ach, dich wollten sie nicht haben.
Weiß ich nicht. Haben sie mir auch nicht geschrieben. Also die haben mir äh das war ja.
So eine ähm also erst habe ich mich da gemeldet. Habe ich gesagt, hier ich möchte das machen. Ihr sucht ja Wahlhelfer. Wurde auch gesagt, wir wir haben nicht genug, ne? Und dann ähm,
Habe ich gesagt, ja okay, ich komme, ne. Und dann habe ich so ein so ein Brief geschrieben, äh Brief bekommen, wo sie sagten so,
Du bist jetzt hier im Wahlvorstand und ähm
Übrigens jetzt kein Spaß mehr, das ist du bist für dieses Ehrenamt jetzt verpflichtet und wenn du da nicht auftauchst, dann keine Ahnung, kommst in den Knast oder so, ne? Also ist auch vielen Dank, herzlich willkommen, ich habe mich gerne für diesen freiwilligen Dienst gemeldet, ne. Aber ist ja klar, dass sie eben auch da dann Planungssicherheit brauchen müssen und nicht irgendwelche Zicken, die
halt sagen, ihr macht das hier freiwillig, ihr könnt mir gar nichts, klar, aber kam nichts mehr. Und jetzt bin ich verunsichert, weil ich nicht weil dann würde ich an dem Wochenende nämlich wegfahren.
Ich habe ja, ich habe ja schon gewählt.
Was hast du gewählt, okay?
Also mich hält da nix.
Ja, ich habe ja ich habe mir meine meine Unterlagen schon mal schicken lassen, weil das so viele Zettel sind.
Ja, ich auch. Habe ich mir auch schinken lassen, schon mal gemacht und werde das, habe ich auch schon abgeschickt wieder.
Schon eingetütet, das habe ich noch nicht gemacht, weil ich dachte mir, ich will trotzdem vielleicht mal so dieses Feeling haben, äh das auch so richtig dann im Wahlkreis äh wie heißt das, weil.
Wahl wie heißt das denn nun mal?
Wahllokal.
Wahllokal, genau, im Wahllokal.
Einzuschmeißen. Das darf man ja leider, ja, kann ich machen, ne.
Steht dir keiner im Wege.
Ja, das das wird sich zeigen.
Ob da nicht irgend so ein Leugner wieder irgendeiner, der wieder irgendwas leugnet. Bundestagswahl alles nicht wahr, nicht real.
Ja, oh, jetzt lachen wir noch. Okay, Leute, das war's äh von unserer Seite her und ähm wir hören uns dann vielleicht nächste Woche, oder? Weiß ich nicht genau, ob das klappt. Wir werden's sehen. Lasst euch überraschen.
Bis bald.
Bis bald, tschau, tschau.